[Music]
there's been some talk in the press
about vince gilligan doing a show for
cbs okay
i think that's just an internet rumor
okay
i happen to know exactly what vince
gilligan is working on in fact this is a
big scoop vince has picked our show to
announce
his next big project take a look
an important announcement from the
creator of breaking bad
with breaking bad finally wrapping up
people have been asking me what my next
project will be another tv show a movie
no something even better
for today forward i'm dedicating my
career to creating handcrafted walnut
dioramas like this one
i call this one nuts about fishing
because it's a it's a walnut and he's
fishing
i had debated calling him old man in the
sea but that obviously would not work
because he's clearly between the ages of
seven and nine
and this one the walnut is playing golf
the the eye fell off but i can probably
fix that
this is of course greg norman
as you can see it's two under par
and if you like breaking bad you'll love
this
all your favorite characters rendered in
loving detail
except as
walnuts there's walls and jet i'm sorry
there's jessie
there's walt and hank
and good old gus frank and i didn't
feature this one this is uh hannah
gunn's real hair
gathered it while she was sleeping
the creative possibilities are obviously
limitless the walnut could be playing
basketball walnut could be playing
billiards walnuts could be playing
tennis or
ice hockey the walnut could be playing
canadian rules football okay
the wallet could get you some shopping
for other walnuts
the walnut diorama collection from vince
gilligan look it's been a pretty
stressful couple of years
[Applause]